- Okay, so Cheryl who
sustained more injuries?
I'm just curious,
over the years, you are your partners?
- Well I've had 22 partners,
'cause I danced with Emmitt Smith twice.
- I thought you were gonna
to say I've had 22 injuries.
- [Cheryl] Oh, I hope not.
- I was like, Oh my God never be a dancer.
This is a PSA-
- But they've never
been mine, not so much me
more like I've been injuring
my partners just cause
it's the, first of all
the schedule is just really crazy.
So we have seven days of, seven
days a week for about three
and a half months, right?
And we're just pounding our bodies.
And especially for these
celebrities that come on the show,
they're not used to doing this.
They're moving body parts that
they've never moved before.
Even, so athletes get injured.
I injured, I wouldn't
say I, I wouldn't take
full responsibility, but I'm definitely
taking some, Ray Lewis was
my partner last season,
first football player to ever get injured.
Yeah, my fault.
And then we had Tom DeLay.
I danced with fractured both his feet,
Cristian de la Fuente,
I broke his arm live
on television when we did the Samba.
And at the very end we had this dip
and then all of a sudden I
feel my head just crashed
to the dance floor.
And then Tom Bergeron at the
time had cut to commercial
'cause he broke his arm.
- I'm I don't think that you're the best
person to promote yourself
as a dance partner-
- No, probably not.
But you know, it's okay.
It's all right.
I'm just saying caution.
- Yeah.